which party is more concerned with
people like you
i chose the 18 to 34 demographic and you
can see
41 say democrats 30
say neither 25 percent say republicans
and i probably fall in that neither camp
and i assume most people watching do
that's why
a lot of the arguments coming from the
democrats on this issue don't make sense
because they lump the neither and the
republican groups together yeah even
though like the neither side is like
well i guess i'll vote for a republican
because the democrats are nuts but i
don't like republicans at all yeah well
and it's also the case that for me i'm
very conservative but i don't really
feel the republican party has like my
best interests in mind as a person
either and i think most republicans
don't feel that way it's it's actually
very interesting that 41 percent uh say
they think the democratic party has
their interests and minds be in mind
because what that says to me is
democrats are just much more likely to
fall in lockstep with the party line and
say oh the politician who told me they
have my best interest in mine has my
best interest in mind i had a
conversation with stephen crowder and he
asked me about my stance on abortion and
then i was like i've my family you know
i grew up we were we were pro-choice
these arguments we heard it was always
about there being some reasonable
restrictions
but now the issue i have i guess is like
you know that what's that woman's name
michelle wolf
saluting to abortion saying everyone
gets abortions lena dunham saying she
wished she had one and i'm like that
doesn't represent me or my family and my
community at all
and so which party do i vote for the
republicans want to ban it outright i'm
like okay well i don't know if i agree
with that the democrats want zero
restrictions and they literally have
people who are like at the point of
birth the baby can be killed they have
it was northam i think right in virginia
where he said the baby will be delivered
and made considerable and then the
mother and the doctor will have a
conversation on what to do next and i
was like what what yeah i was like who
am i voting for right now so when we say
politically homeless you know i don't
care if these zealot cult people are
like you're a republican i'm like sure i
guess
because like not
snipping the spinal cord of a baby at
nine months right as it's being born if
i have a choice between not doing that
and doing that i'd be like i guess i'm
voting republican you know yeah can i
just mention what we're thinking before
we jump into this i think it goes even
deeper than that because obviously you
and i disagree on this i don't believe
there should be any exception abortion
should be completely illegal however
it's not just that the democratic party
is even necessarily saying abortion up
until the last second of pregnancy in a
number of states as you mentioned there
have been discussions about even
allowing the child to die after the
abortion has failed but on top of that
our you know quote unquote very catholic
president joe biden
has talked about appealing the hyde
amendment and the height amendment
prevents federal funding from paying for
abortions so basically the position of
the left is that yes taxpayers should be
funding this
i want to pull up that video
like the most extreme possible position
i don't trust a lot of these news out so
i'm going to try and find this video
oh oh we have reuters
they have the video i'm surprised i want
to make sure i play this
so a meme shared by over 70 000 people
are they going to play the full video
oh i can't you can't wait hold on here
we go
okay this is 50 minutes long maybe i'll
just have to try and find it also can i
ask you we obviously we're just having a
conversation on which political party
people feels represents them like where
do you land there do you feel either
party against you or
no i i really don't i just i feel very
cynically about both um i i think the
democrats are wrong for obvious reasons
but then the republicans are just kind
of
putting up a fake opposition to that and
then siphoning off money from all their
donors and and then obviously not really
putting up any resistance to it
considering
the last few decades yeah they both
democrats and republicans do this it's
all just part of the same machine it's
just
barack obama
so this is i i have to fact-check me on
this one but i'm pretty sure barack
obama campaigned on codifying roe v wade
once the they had the presidency the
house and the senate and then once he
gets elected he's like well it's not a
top concern for me so i'm not going to
do it we we heard this from marjorie
taylor greene
that i think was margaret taylor green
thomas massey that even the republicans
will be like we don't really want to ban
obamacare because we need the wedge
issue so they purposefully tried was
that thomas massey i think i don't think
i remember who it was i don't know oh no
no no was the other guy
it was the other freedom caucus guy we
had on what was his name
older guy freedom caucus anyway he was
saying that they go they go to him and
they're like we have the vote to end
obamacare but don't do it because we
need to rally up our base you know we
don't want to lose the issue wow i'm
going to play this for you from vox all
right let's listen to this exception
there was a very contentious committee
hearing yesterday when fairfax county
kathy tran made her case for lifting
restrictions on third trimester
abortions as well as other restrictions
now in place and she was pressed by a
republican delegate about whether her
bill would permit an abortion even as a
woman is essentially dilating ready to
give birth and she answered
that it would permit an abortion at that
stage of labor do you support her
measure and explain her answer yeah you
know i wasn't there uh julie and i i
certainly can't
speak for uh delegate tran but um i will
tell you one
first thing i would say this is why
decisions such as this should be made by
providers physicians
and the
mothers and fathers that that are
involved
there are you know when we talk about
third trimester abortions these are done
uh with the consent of obviously the the
mother with the consent
of the physicians more than one
physician by the way um and it's done in
cases where there may be severe
deformities there may be a a fetus
that's non-viable so in this particular
example uh if a mother is in labor i can
tell you exactly what would happen
the infant would be delivered
the infant would be kept comfortable
the infant would be resuscitated if
that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mother so so i think
this was really blown out of proportion
uh but again
out of proportion
about what
he's talking about deformities and
non-viable fetuses but he said it would
be resuscitated and then a discussion
would happen in the context of an
abortion it sounds a lot like to me like
he was saying a living baby would be
kept comfortable and resuscitated and
then we discuss whether we kill it
and also maybe i'm wrong maybe i'm crazy
about that well maybe i should that's
that is the most straightforward reading
of what he just said and also when he
talks about wait wait i'm sorry i'm
sorry i just i just
even outside of that psychotic context
yeah
the woman asking the question is talking
about
third trimester abortions where the baby
the woman is dilating and the baby is
about to be born and there would be no
restrictions
and he's like yeah right okay well you
see the thing is
stop right there that in and of itself
to me is just beyond psychosis yeah he
gave the most i'm not a biologist answer
ever to that question he's like well
yeah it's betraying the doctor and
you're lost in his manipulation well i'm
just trying to the law is the law is not
about aborting deformed babies that's
that's why i'm bringing that up because
he specifically said it's about or at
least he thinks it's about deformities
and non-viability so if a deformed child
is born i just don't see why that would
be a reason of whether or not you could
kill it i ju that
either kill it or don't but don't it's
not about like i mean i guess if the
deformity is so horrific like it's born
with one lung
helena as somebody who doesn't have a
very strong opinion based on what you
just heard what do you think
i mean i i think that's
it's obviously very wrong to kill a
living baby like don't don't get me
wrong and i think like a lot of people
they'll argue that this is just
it's an extreme version of like a
pro-choice stance but most women who are
getting abortions like aren't you know
killing their living babies but then i
think to myself well then what does it
say about someone like him uh even if he
does have that more moderate stance on
abortion for i guess normal women um
what does it say about his logic and his
reasoning more moderate
well i mean i don't know it's like
people will say i'm not saying that
again i don't agree like i'm against
abortion in all cases but i believe what
she's saying is
he he's representing up arguably the
more common position on abortion but
then he's also representing this a very
uncommon yeah and people say that this
isn't a representation of like the
average pro-choice person but if the
average pro-choice person would defend
this what does that say about like their
their ideology in general yeah that's a
very good point
he was the governor at the time well and
shouldn't if if this didn't represent
pro-choice or shouldn't they be out
there decrying it how could you say this
how could you make our movement look so
horrible by smearing us in this way he
really that was word salad what he put
out there like i didn't even catch the
deformity part until today and i've
heard him say that before
and that's that's like
that's why people aren't speaking about
it because they don't understand what he
said reuters like missing context
i'm like dude we all heard what he said
man
i like how that is just such a magic
phrase you can slap that on everything
partly false
partly false
northern was not supporting infanticide
yo he literally said the baby would be
resuscitated in the discussion would
ensue in the context of abortion what
what do you have been talking about what
are they going to discuss but he's
gender why didn't he say outright
i think that if a woman is dilating you
should not be able to kill the baby at
that point is it hard to say
that's it's just insane it's hard for
him to say though but i think part of
why it's hard for him to say is because
he knows that the radical left has an
immense amount of power in the
democratic party he's a coward who
doesn't want to stand for human life and
he's aware that he will destroy his
career as a member of the democratic
party if he says anything about any kind
of abortion
i think he honestly
supports the
the activity of
killing a fully developed human baby
that is just born that has a deformity
like a serious deformity could be true
as well yeah i mean that's certainly
what he said that's absolutely what he
said yeah
yeah
yeah i mean you really gotta strip apart
deformity because you could have like
your finger could be bent and that
you're considered deformed as a child
because one finger is bent like that's
not a reason to abort a kid well and i
agree with what you said earlier that
they're i mean whether someone is
deformed or not that's not a reason to
kill somebody some deformities are so
horrific that you might actually save
the child some suffering i know i'm
being it's an extreme example but like
you know severe brain damage i don't
know man but then you ask that that
severely brain damaged person when
they're 30 or 40 like are you glad
you're alive but like what kind of
destruction are they got not destruction
overt destruction but what kind of like
you know sucking away of resources are
severely deformed people on society
when i say deformed it's a very vague
statement because it's not about like
autism that i'm not talking about that
kind of thing and even if i don't even
think that adds a formula well can i i
just want to mention one thing um
because this is obviously a much bigger
discussion i i just want to
sort of say this um to think about you
mentioned them consuming resources but
what if it's the case that
resources are there for humans and not
the other way around
the purpose of research
homo superior i don't like it i don't
think that things are here for us i
think we just happen to be here and at
the top of the food chain but if we're
talking about resources like what if it
is the case that human life is
intrinsically valuable and
the reason resources are valuable is
because they help us they help keep us
alive so to say it's better off if this
person is dead because that'll conserve
resources is self-defeating because the
purpose of the resource is to keep a
person alive only because if people have
unlimited food they grow exponentially
and overcrowd and destroy the system
that they're like the deer population
overeats you know you and so there's
this built-in kind of like starvation
method into humanity that keeps us from
overgrowing almost it seems like i think
i think we need to paul the audience if
you disagree with ian hit the like
button
and if you agree with sheamus hit the
like button yes um
smash that like button
i think the problem with that is that's
malthusianism right and that thinking
has been debunked by basically all of
the historical analyses so as the world
population has increased poverty in
global poverty has decreased
significantly as more people have
existed there's been less poverty there
have been more resources getting a
little wide on the conversation let's
make one more point before we move on
one of the deformities
that people refer to
is or one of the we'll call it issues
that the left often refers to as to why
abortions should be allowed as down
syndrome
and there was uh there's a very famous
video of a man with down syndrome i
think he's testifying before congress
right saying that they would have me
killed
why it's like these people are alive
they're functioning they they are
functioning human beings but it's just
because the traits they have are
undesirable people want them terminated
before they could be alive but the
people who are alive are happy people i
get it that like humans are we want to
be more than animals but we're animals
and we're just smart animals and like
animals will destroy their young if
they're not healthy often
other non-human animals like it's just
they're gonna hold back the pack you
can't you can't risk everyone else's
existence because of one small feeble
child and so they'll destroy it at birth
you know but our society is not
crumbling because we're allowing
disabled people to live our society's
crumbling because we don't care enough
for one another and we view other human
beings as objects in that how do don't
think it's crumbling i mean i i guess
it's just a way of looking at it
i think the united states
i mean there's a lot of tremendous
victories that the pro liberty or right
whatever you want to call it has has
achieved recently like elon musk buying
twitter but i think the leak of the roe
v wade initial draft shows for the first
time in history this happened like yeah
our institutions are basically on fire
20th century institutions man there are
18th century institutions that we're
using thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time